so we've been telling you about the
first shipment of the copen 19 vaccine
being delivered here to nevada it's
already been administered in fact
to a lot of health care workers over at
umc 8 news now reporter sally jaramillo
is live outside of a different hospital
she's at sunrise
with who's next to get the vaccine and
also reaction to its arrival today sally
denise i reached out to many valley
hospitals to see
when they will get the vaccine here at
sunrise hospital
they are preparing right now they just
finished a clinic exercise but are
awaiting the vaccine
centennial hills hospital is also
awaiting the vaccine but the v.a
southern nevada health system
will begin vaccinations under health
care workers tomorrow i spoke to some
people in our community
while some say they are for it others
are against it 71 year old ed martin is
waiting for his turn to get the vaccine
he believes it's good not only for las
vegas for but for the entire
world kayla stringer along with her
three children got coveted this year but
she says she's done research and it's
something she wouldn't want her or her
kids to get
she's concerned about the side effects
deservedly so i think the health care
workers as well as all front line
workers
that are uh are should be at the front
of the line
absolutely i i post hardly support the
tear system what concerns you
getting the cover shot and getting
covered and dying to be honest that's
because like when you take the flu shot
you get
so sick now you have a cobra shot so
it's like you know i can take this and
get sick and die
as for how early the majority of the
population could get the
vaccine sometime around march reporting
live sally jaramillo 8 news
now